all right i hope everybody is ready for
the most exciting night in american
politics
not tonight i just mean i hope people
are generally ready for that night
if at some point we were to have that
but tonight we have
night one of the democratic national
convention
we have quite a schedule on our hands i
will be letting you know i even showered
for this one my friends i even showered
for this one
um i will be letting you know the
trajectory
for our coverage of this election up
through and to
election day and beyond as donald trump
has said we might not know the results
for years
so we might have a lot of coverage uh to
come
so very very exciting things um will i
take calls today
we just started we just started so we
will see about that but we do have a new
discord which i tested on the earlier
stream to see if it would work for phone
calls
it worked beautifully i don't know if we
get
50 i mean if i'm doing this every night
you know i don't know that i can be
taking calls every night but if we get
50 new members and patrons tonight
i will open up the phone lines the
discord
tubes at the end of tonight's uh
presentation well
i don't know you know you got to make me
do it you got to make me do it
we are expecting let's look at the
schedule for tonight by the way we are
going to be keeping
a very very close eye on donald trump's
twitter
um donald trump i'm guessing might be
triggered by some of what we're going to
be seeing tonight seeing tonight
and so we're going to be keeping an eye
on his twitter uh you might have seen
earlier today a number of reporters
said that donald trump on the flight
home from wisconsin said he plans to
pardon someone very very important
tomorrow
who is not edward snort snowden nor
michael flynn
so that's certainly something to look
forward to i guess
uh and then as far as the schedule today
i believe that this is the schedule in
order
it is senator amy klobuchar senator
catherine cortez
masto governor andrew cuomo of new york
governor gretchen whitmer of michigan
congressman jim clyburn we'll hear from
the convention chairman benny thompson
that's often the most boring thing it's
like when the president of the academy
speaks at the oscars and it's sort of
like a snooze fest then we will hear
from congresswoman gwen moore
senator doug jones there will be
performances which i've been told
i've been whitelisted instead of being
blacklisted as i often am or browning
out
i've been told i've been whitelisted so
that i shouldn't have any copyright
issues with the music performances we
will be hearing from maggie rogers leon
bridges
billy porter and steven stills and then
all of this somehow happening in just a
two-hour period
um senator bernard sanders and we will
hear from former first lady michelle
obama so it's really quite an
evening that as far as i know we'll be
starting in just about 10 minutes
with senator amy klobuchar
so a lot a lot a lot going on
um thank you and welcome to comstock
rocker and green party trevor for
supporting this on twitch
um i also want to say thanks to chris
blazinski chris blezinski
who is new member number one today one
at joinpackman.com uh
and i guess okay yeah i mean i guess
that's the thing if we get 50 new
members and patrons i will open the
phone lines
during and or after this all goes down
let's look at some of the super chats
that are very powerfully coming in from
people
uh andrew moore asks am i expecting to
see putin
she and kim at pog champs they're
apparently world class chess players
yeah trump earlier referring to a bunch
of dictators as world-class chess
players unclear if he meant that
literally and if so do they favor
uh the sicilian defense we don't know
but my first pog champs match
should be scheduled soon the car the
tournament starts friday
i don't know when my first day is going
to be
kat mccarry says let's do this pacman my
thoughts exactly
jacob ball says every day a new pacman
video is out
is the new most exciting day in american
politics
you know what's crazy uh we published a
video
only four and a half hours ago
which already has 400
wait a second hold on what's the number
400 435
000 views so it's getting 100 000 views
an hour
okay that's bonkers that's bonkers my
friends
uh zach bushman says do you ever catch
yourself using trumpisms elements of
strongly etc in your daily life
outside the show i constantly say to my
girlfriend
from the standpoint of even when it
makes no sense and she just rolls her
eyes
matthew says ever heard of liberal
viewers live sunday clip roundup
no i have not chaka seki says is joe
biden going to slam uppers to keep up
with trump's manic frenzied and sweaty
pace
by the way trump tweeted save the post
office today
yeah it's i mean it's just there's no
clue what here it is save the post
office
um i'll be watching trump's tweets
during the whole thing i also was
thinking i may do some tweeting in real
time so during this thing i might head
over to my twitter
and i might you know as as the kids say
i might i might live tweet
some elements of this while you guys
watch me so if i do switch over to this
during the presentations
you don't have to start panicking
you know oh you switched you switched uh
i'm deliberately going to be showing you
the peak behind the curtain at crafting
of tweets
which there's really not much to it i
hate to say but i will show you how i
craft the tweets
uh okay other super chats the super
chats are just
flying in um do
brian says do i see a scenario where
trump is president and republicans lose
the senate and dems maintain the house
sure yeah i mean that anything's
possible anything is is possible right
now
dan mccord says sorry david just joined
your broadcast are you covering the full
two hours will you allow
bernie and michelle to speak without
interruption um
i am covering the full two hours unless
if if the audience i have no idea
whether people want me to cover this or
not i don't know what the level of
interest is in this
so we haven't started yet we've got
about 4 000 people watching
on youtube we have 460
460 watching on twitch and about 460
also on facebook
um my goal is to cover everything
but if there's really a lack of interest
i might bail
and just go practice chess for the chess
tournament okay
so but let's hope that it's a big
evening and then we're going to cover
everything now as far as not
interrupting bernie and michelle
i don't know okay people saying 570 on
twitch it hasn't uh updated on my end it
still says 462 but i'm sure it will
update
uh we'll see we have a while and we can
decide about uh you know i like to do
commentary and
you know we'll see we'll see um
chris says first time watching a live
stream live welcome chris glad to have
you here
matt chavez says you're only winning the
race because you're running faster
yeah so people may not know this um but
there's been a really really
ugly uh situation
i guess we would say um let me pull this
up
involving the progressive media space oh
i had info on one of our speakers ready
to go here see i plan ahead for you guys
um the david pakman show and sam cedars
channel are embroiled in a battle to 1
million subscribers right now
we are at 9 4 actually that's wrong
we're at 9 50. this just takes a little
while to update
where are we exactly 9 50
wow we could hit 9.51 actually
but in any case right now it's it's 9 50
to 9 22
putting us a 28 000 ahead
and there's this really lame uh
thing that some people have been have
been right i don't know who's saying
this but i got emails from people saying
david
you're being criticized for having more
subscribers than sam
because you're doing videos that go
viral
and live streams
that's the that's it it's like saying
you're winning only because you ran the
race faster
what you got a higher score on the test
only because you answered questions
correctly that's cheap
how lame is that it's like guys yet the
whole point of this
is you gain subscribers by doing things
people engage with
building community through the live
streams for example
doing videos that people want to what
give me come on guys
that's the criticism i'm doing content
people want to watch
unbelievable okay um
[Music]
gr says please have hassan [ __ ] on your
show i'd love to see you too
i uh the last two times i um
contacted hassan to do you know a thing
he didn't even write back
and it's it's sad i don't like it i
don't like it at all
sinful solutions asks about the sam
cedar update yep i just uh gave that
update we are at it's actually 9
50 and 9 22. i don't know why my phone
actually says we're almost at 9
51. uh but social blade is is a little
bit
slow so you know we'll have to wait and
see about that
tanner audia says would you ever
uh make a run for political office no
idea
wouldn't uh wouldn't rule anything out
and thanks to
ms juxta for subscribing for seven
months
with twitch prime i very very much
appreciate that if you're just finding
the stream randomly looking for dnc
coverage welcome come on in glad to have
you here
david alexander is new member number two
today
and let's get right to the introductions
we are attempting to fulfill
our national purpose to create and
sustain a society in which
all of us are equal
and we've made history along the way
there is not a liberal america
and a conservative america there is the
united states
of america right we must pledge once
more
to march into the future we are a
different society than we were in 1961.
brothers and sisters do you want to go
back
or do you want to keep america moving
forward
yeah well our motto
is when they go low we go high
we never bow we never bend we never
break no we endure and we always
always always move forward
this election we've engaged a historic
number of americans in the democratic
process
and now we have to overcome the odds
once again to build back
better than before we lead not only by
the example of our power
but by the power of our example we are
america
second to none and we own the finish
line
don't forget it we
are democrats and we're ready to lead
again we're coming together on august
17th
all across america be there
wow wow
wow did we lose the feed no we've still
got it all right
i i actually am curious how they're
going to organize all of this will there
be
a sort of host is it are people just
going to be in their living rooms
etc so far it's not going great i mean
the last 15 seconds have not been great
here we go
[Music]
wow
good evening i'm eva longoria bastogne
and welcome to the 2020 democratic
national convention
uniting america every four years we
come together to reinforce our democracy
this year we've come to save it it's
going to take all of us
so tonight we stand together united by
the values we cherish
decency respect justice and the
opportunity to rise up
we always hear that line about this
being the most important election of our
lifetimes
but this year it really is the past
few months have tested us all we've lost
more than a hundred and seventy thousand
family members and friends to covid this
tragedy is compounded by the loss of
jobs and income
but it's not just the past few months
the past i turned it down a little guys
everybody relax
as a nation diminished and divided
and yet in the middle of the fear and
sorrow and the uncertainty
people have come together because they
know
we are better than this america is
better than this
and so we choose to act inspired by the
three
sacred words that breathed life into our
nation
we the people
i guess it is live because that
transition would have been cleaner if it
was pre-taped i think
oh come on now okay we ready
i think i learned this in middle school
third
fifth grade can i say this in spanish
so should i read just this line or the
whole thing
just justice strength liberty
liberty liberty
let's do this we the people we
the people we the people nosotros
we the people we the people we the
people
of the united states
in order to form a more perfect union
establish justice
ensure domestic tranquility provide for
the common defense
promote the general welfare and secure
the blessings of
liberty to ourselves and
our posterity do ordain and establish
this constitution
for the united states of america
we the people we the people we the
people
we the people we the people we're the
people the people
we the people of the united states we're
the people call the 48th quadrennial
democratic
national convention to order
what a day what a day i pledge
allegiance to the flag of the united
states of america and to the republic
for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
[Music]
it's a little cringy so far but okay
they're doing they're getting into the
[Music]
spirit
[Music]
quite a concept
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
when i see this it's like trump
suggested injecting bleach
do we need any of this stuff or do we
just vote the guy out now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
i feel like the northern mariana islands
didn't get enough recognition there
oh my name is reverend gabriel salguero
let us pray
almighty god what we confess that our
nation needs you
guys come up come up
okay um this is the start of the
first day of the democratic national
convention
um they're doing a prayer right now
and i i just
i'm finding myself at a loss a little
bit um
for words i don't know about
you guys but i just am unsure
about a lot of this and i was pretty
fired up going in and we're gonna be
ending with bernie and
with michelle obama today but
a little bit of what's going on i'm not
loving i have to tell you
but i'm not a political strategist maybe
all this makes sense
but i don't i don't know um
yeah it's like it hasn't even started
yet and it's yeah i know
two hours for people wondering how long
this is gonna go all right let's get
back to it
it's i mean it's you know why are we
doing religious stuff
for you i pray this in the matchless
name of jesus
amen jesus what welcome to our
convention across
america isn't this supposed to be
secular but instead we figured out a
safe and
responsible way to come together to
share our ideas and talk about the
future of our country
and that's the kind of leadership we
need right now that's the kind of
leadership that joe biden and kamala
harris
will bring to the white house so during
the next four nights
we will gather safely from our homes to
listen
to learn to be inspired to act to vote
and to build that more perfect union
i am honored to be with you this evening
i'm here tonight as a ninth generation
texan as a daughter of a veteran and a
teacher
as a mother as a voter and as a patriot
i share joe biden's belief that the
story of america is one of ordinary
people
coming together to do extraordinary
things and at our best our country
rewards hard work we celebrate diversity
we look
out for each other and we lift one
another up
so tonight we're going to begin with the
simple kindness we've been extending to
each other a lot
lately we're going to check in with
folks around the country and ask
how are you doing as many of you know
small businesses employ
half of all u.s workers tonight we have
scott
scott you are a small business owner
from swarthmore pennsylvania
small businesses have been hit so hard
in this crisis so many small businesses
how are you doing how are you managing
well you know it's uh it's been rough uh
you know rough uh is a
nice word to say it uh my wife and i 31
years ago
uh began our business and quite honestly
over
all these years uh we face some
adversity and challenges
but uh to be honest with nothing nothing
like we are today
we've literally had to reinvent our
business uh
several times since the beginning of the
year just uh
just to stay afloat and um you know we
uh our revenue for example
is off about 40 percent
uh are we have half of the employees
that we had uh pre-covered
and you know our customers are a little
scared
our our employees are sometimes afraid
to come to work
because of the kovid and to be honest
with you i'm just frustrated
i don't understand how we got here we
are
the greatest nation in the world
and uh it just seems to me that you know
maybe if we just came together
on this one issue alone
maybe as americans and being united hey
guys i
i don't want to interrupt here but i
think you won't mind
how are they gonna have all these
speakers and
three concerts in two hours if they're
just going to be checking in with
doug is the timing making sense to
anyone yes who is 15 years old from west
orange new
jersey she is a literary activist and
author and she is the founder of
thousand black girl books marley so many
young people
are struggling with the changes due to
covid how are you doing
i'm doing all right you know i feel
better every day i feel more hopeful
i thought this was going to be a few
weeks at first where i wouldn't see my
friends and i would just stick it out
but obviously as it's grown longer i
really want to focus on activism and
still
spreading important messages given the
fact that i can't go out
so i started doing virtual read alouds
online which has been so fun getting to
interact and meet new kids and encourage
and promote the joy that we can find
in reading and in learning it's also
super fun to see teenagers like me
is this stuff off of a prompter like i
don't even understand what this
is that they care about is this live
have that space in school
so i hope that a year from now you know
we get to go back and be safe
and be protected who will still have
these conversations and still have a new
possibility in a new world
yes thank you so much marley you were
such an inspiration i don't think i was
doing half of what you're doing at 15
and i
i love seeing how brave and creative
your generation is
to creating change so thank you thank
you so much for your
work let's check in with rick
rick you are a farmer from volant
pennsylvania
your farm has been in your family for
generations
what of the trade wars and the pandemic
done to your family's life work guys i
i'm sorry
i i want to win we have to absolutely
destroy
donald trump and we're going to have to
overcome
voter suppression the kneecapping of the
post office
possibly people with guns i don't know
that this helps us
win i i'm guys i want to win
then whenever you compound the effects
of the the kova 19 virus
nobody could have prevented that it's a
shame where leadership
misinformed the people like myself and
the country
on what was coming down the road
you know my biggest my biggest concern
is that if uh these trends continue with
this type of leadership
uh i will be the last generation farming
on this farm
yeah it's a scary thought and i'm sure a
lot of farmers i don't
feel the same way you know i don't have
the answers but
uh past experiences if something doesn't
work for you it's time for a change
and that's why supporting joe biden all
the way
well thank you so much uh rick i
couldn't agree with you more you know we
need meaningful change and
and leadership that will support family
farms like yours so so we wish you the
best
thank you for sharing your story finally
let's hear from michelle
from my home state of texas michelle you
are a
school nurse and a mother in el paso
how are you preparing for the new school
year
hi eva well we've already started school
but it is a little challenging because
every day something seems to change we
start one way one day and we have to
change it the next day
and i know that right now it's kind of
sad not to see the kiddos when we're
back but i know that that will change
we're going to have to adapt and
persevere
but honestly right now all i can think
about is keeping my kiddos safe
i know back in march you know we had
them at home and we were doing okay but
now they're wanting us to take them back
to school
and it's a little scary with all the
uprising and covet cases
and so i just want to say that i am
committed to take care of my family
my students and all my staff at my
school i will do whatever it takes to
ensure that we are all
ready to go back to school safe and
healthy and i know that i am optimistic
to move forward with our life and
joe and joe biden will be the one to
take us there i just want to say
for everyone to please remember to wash
their hands and wear their mask because
we're all in this together
thank you michelle i think there's
nothing more difficult for us as moms to
than to see our children suffer and so i
think you're doing a great job of
guiding them through this
very difficult time and thank you for
the work you do as a nurse
it's truly heroic um i've really
enjoyed talking to all of you i think i
have one last question
do you believe that change is coming do
you believe that better days are ahead
yes yes
[Laughter]
well thank you for taking the time to to
speak with us and sharing your thoughts
you are the we and we the people and you
are who this convention is about
in 1776 the declaration of independence
we hold these truths to be self-evident
these words these words are the basis
for the american creed
equality equity fairness decency
america didn't live up to that promise
for most of the people at the time
a prompt the people of color whip for
women but we were born of an idea
that every single solitary person can
have a chance no matter where they're
from given half a chance
there's not a single thing they cannot
do if they work at it nothing's beyond
the capacity
we had hoped to have our convention in
the city of festivals milwaukee
wisconsin this year
of course we're not able to do that but
we'll be hearing from several of
wisconsin's leaders throughout this
convention
starting with congresswoman gwen moore
okay so they're doing a different order
than on the website
hi i'm gwen moore and it's my
honor to represent milwaukee and
congress and to kick off the 2020
democratic convention oh i sure wish you
all were here in the city of milwaukee
which takes its name from the languages
of the first peoples
interpreted as as good land and
gathering place
by the waters this is a city where blood
was shed for labor rights where a
fugitive slave was freed from prison
where women's right to vote was first
ratified
but today we gather virtually however we
gather unified in spirit unified in our
values and purpose
to heal divisions and together move the
nation confidently
into a prosperous inclusive future
what better way to gather than all
across america
to nominate my beloved friend joe biden
to be
46th president of the united states of
america
with my vip vp nominee
sister kamala harris by his side
tonight we are gathered to reclaim
the soul of america so if you're ready
to come together america text
join to 303 30.
thank you i love you all and god bless
you
wow that's in it whoa whoa that's an
entire speech
from the standpoint of like the
[Music]
[Music]
schedules
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
level four hype train's doing well
that's something
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i've been i've been told i've been
whitelisted in terms of the music
so supposedly i'm not going to have any
issue that's why that's why i'm not
muting it i've been you know
very powerfully in touch with everybody
before i hope that's the case
otherwise i'm screwed but i didn't think
i was going to have a problem
i should mute it anyway yeah i don't i
mean people are telling me in the chat
to calm down but
i don't i don't know if this is good i'm
not sure if this is good
um i'll thank
supporters while we while we wait um
robert braga is new member number three
i did say i'd open the phone lines if we
get to
50 andrea larson
is number four today we're slowly but
surely working our way up
um fran smith
is number five we've just got a musical
interlude here with bruce springsteen
that we've
briefly stepped away from um
i see a lot of people on twit twitch
seems
more horrified than youtube
right now although youtube viewers are
bailing
uh like this is a cringe stream so i
don't know what
that kind of tells us adam white says oh
my god we're going to lose the election
uh a drumpf twittler asks says
david how are you sober i'm not um
robert havens asked whether they hired
the local public access station to i
don't think the production value is bad
i just am unsure about
the whole sort of approach i guess i
don't know
not a single thing we cannot do if we do
it together
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the idea of us calling ourselves the
united states of america
feels feels like it's pretty wrong right
now
fairly ashamed to say it but i'm one of
many who voted for
the current president donald trump i
challenge you to think back to
what made you vote for donald trump in
2016.
i know i sure have and i've registered
as a democrat for the first time in my
life
i'm doing that because i think this
election is bigger than any political
party
what i think in light of current events
if nothing else we need more than
anything
is a proven leader donald trump's
rhetoric
is it's divisive it's dangerous
it's also really difficult to vote for
someone who essentially has
zero platform right now four months out
from the election
joe biden on the other hand has a very
detailed plan
things like unity education climate
preservation
racial inequality and even health care
we have a chance right now to look
ourselves in the mirror
and go vote for a proven leader with a
history
of caring about others and putting truly
putting all americans first
[Music]
our nation is facing a lot right now and
over the next four nights we're going to
cover it all
but tonight we're going to talk about
three specific crises we face
the pandemic an economic downturn and an
ongoing systemic racial injustice that's
smart because those are the top three
issues according to polling so that
those are the three to focus on trump's
underwater on them and they are the top
three for voters
across from the white house our next
speaker stood up
stood strong and turned that place into
the black lives matter plaza
in their honor please welcome mayor
muriel
bowser
was this even hello i'm muriel bowser
mayor of washington d.c
the story of our nation's capital is a
story of reckoning
it was here that john lewis and dr king
spoke on the steps of the lincoln
memorial
it was here that millions of women and
men flooded the streets for the women's
march
it was here that just weeks ago
americans don
face mask and safely and peacefully
protested
the death of george floyd but while we
were peacefully protesting donald trump
was plotting
he stood in front of one of our most
treasured houses of worship
and held a bible for a photo op he sent
troops and camouflage into our streets
he sent tear gas into the air
and federal helicopters too i knew if he
did this to d.c
he would do it to your city or your town
and that's when i said enough
i said enough for every black and brown
american who has experienced
injustice enough for every american who
believes
in justice but i said enough for another
reason
too i have a two-year-old daughter and i
want her to grow up in an america where
she's not scared to walk to the store
an america where she's safe behind the
doors of her own home
an america where the president doesn't
fan the flames of racism and looks out
for
all of us so i created black lives
matter plaza right behind me
as a place where we could come together
to say
enough and by coming together this
november to elect joe biden and kamala
harris
we will say next because we can't just
paint those words behind me
we can't just say those words we have to
live those words
we have to undo the laws and systems
that have codified racism for far
too long but we have to do something too
each and every one of us challenge our
own biases
if we see something do something
together we can turn this reckoning into
a reimagining of a nation
where we the people means all the people
there were a few people who stood on
this very balcony as thousands of people
peacefully protested in this city
one was our next vice president my
sister kamala harris
the others were members of george
floyd's family who i'm honored to
introduce now
my brother george was selfless he always
made sacrifices for his family
friends and even complete strangers
george had a given spirit
a spirit that has shown up on streets
around our nation
and around the world people of all races
all ages all genders all backgrounds
peacefully protesting in the name of
love
and unity it's a fitting legacy for our
brother
but george should be alive today brianna
taylor should be alive today
ahmad aubrey should be alive today eric
garner should be alive today
stefan clark or tatiana jefferson
sandra bland they should all be alive
today
so it's up to us to carry on the fight
for justice
our actions will be their legacies we
must always find ourselves in what john
lewis called
good trouble for the names we do not
know
the faces we'll never see those
who can't mourn because their murders
didn't go viral
please join me in a moment of silence
to honor george and the many other souls
we lost to hate and injustice
and when this moment ends let's make
sure
we never stop saying their names
foreign
okay um so i don't
think it's going great so far
um let's see what people think
in response to my tweet the rising is a
good song at least
they're kissing babies so far i love it
okay
seems about as engaging as it usually is
the vibe this has the same as hearing
our grandparents telling us what's cool
and hip nowadays
it's different game this year with the
streaming convention i'm praying for the
win
it gets better now that we're on
politics
watching it and i think it's great oh
okay
um
[Music]
somebody telling me to be patient okay
well i guess listen maybe i'm in the
wrong
i guess people disagree people think
it's good um
i don't know a thanks to die hard for
the twitch
subscription breezy has subscribed
vermipost as well
appreciate everybody who's watching on
twitch i really do
um i want to say thanks to samantha
moretta
samantha's new member number six today
remember we opened the phone lines at
50.
also big thank you to kevin klotfelter
have never heard that last name before
clot felter but i like it
you are new member number seven today
and i appreciate that very much as well
casey bates wants policy substance
via super chat harvey willing says how
much do you miss bernie right now well
bernie's speaking today bernie's part of
this
um helen gresser says we need some
dynamic exciting hard-nosed spirit
lifting here
this is very weird right now i feel
queasy i want to win
um malachi says oh no black guy what
does that mean that's really weird
donovan carter says don't let this
phoned in convention distract us from
what we need to vote we all already know
what needs to be done
vote alice wonder says thank you david
for your insightful explanations of the
issues we may not always fully
comprehend i trust your efforts
rocksteady for me says not sure it's
time for entertainment should be serious
yeah i would
i don't know the right order but i don't
know that interspersing entertainment
although i think if you look at the
lyrics here these are sort of activist
songs let's listen a little
[Music]
the tears
over me
[Music]
my sisters and my brothers sang
sing over me
[Music]
okay um man i'm like
unsure what to do
um bae photo says there were always
going to be
elements of cringe i guess so i guess so
uh back to evil longoria now leon
bridges whose
song sweeter featured terrace martin a
song written
after george floyd's murder you know we
have to ask
ourselves how do we the people take the
protest
and turn them into progress how do we
take the changes we're seeing in the
hearts and minds of people and translate
it
into real and lasting change in people's
lives
we need to address the economic
inequalities that this virus has exposed
and worsened
and we need to solve the testing and
healthcare disparities that have led to
people of color
color dying from covet at higher rates
than white people and we need to make it
easier for americans to vote
we have a lot to do and to do this we
need community action
we need congress that can have power to
do it and we need a president
who understands that this is the moment
the moment has come for our nation to
deal with systemic racism
to deal with the growing economic
inequity that exists in our nation
to deal with the denial of the promise
of this nation
made to so many
you know i've said from the outset of
this election
that we're in the battle for the soul of
this nation right
and we are in the battle for the soul of
this nation
what we believe and maybe most
importantly
who we want to be it's all at stake
[Music]
that's truer today than it's ever been
at least in my lifetime
and it's this urgency
it's in this urgency we can find a path
forward
hey everybody how are you thanks for
doing well mr marshmallow
thank you thank you thank you jamiro
tell the rest of folks a little about
your background
i started doing activism when i was 15.
it was
at the intersection of knowing both the
perpetrator and a victim
my brother andre was shot and killed in
philadelphia and it made me realize that
i had a
responsibility almost a collective
responsibility to ensure that that
didn't happen to other young people
and i think that's what's missing in
america right now is our collective
responsibility to each other
and to realize that the person down the
street are around the corner
even across the country that we have a
responsibility to ensure that we're
making sure that they're safe
they have access to education and that
and all we're creating in a world in
which
their differences are celebrated as well
as um protected under the law
i just like if this isn't live and it's
pre-recorded why isn't the video
equality better you know
try to tackle in a way that we haven't
before systemic racism in the city
it really it's about economic
empowerment
because if people are lifted out of
poverty and they
are given an opportunity to feel a stake
in their own future
that goes a long way we're also
challenging
you know all kinds of institutions from
corporations
to community-based organizations to
think about
what they can do better uh to end
systemic racism and make sure that we're
uplifting the quality
of life in communities but also the
voices of people that traditionally
don't have a seat at the table
the president's talking about defunding
the post office and mail-in voting
i mean what do you think we should be
doing mr president well first of all we
have to
change the public discourse around
voting
it should be seen as the a democratic
thing to do
the most patriotic thing we can do and
not a partisan exercise
secondly how do we open up access to
voting
so we could address some of the systemic
problems not only do
should we reauthorize the voting rights
act but we have to go further
most importantly voting should be seen
as a constitutional right that's
guaranteed
and with that level of sight that all
citizens can be assured that they can
have unfeathered access
without being suppressed this is a
watershed moment and we can't lose this
moment we have got to have
action at the national level we have got
to have congressional action we cannot
have 18 000 police departments
and in 2020 have police departments
still allowing uh the use of a knee on
the man's neck
in george floyd uh a lot of us were
shocked and and i think what gives me
hope
acevedo is actually a really interesting
police chief and smart guy
i like seeing his presence hopeful that
we'll have some national
uh standards as it relates to policing
use of force
a national database uh you know
abolishment
of uh prohibition and the national
standard in terms of uh
chokeholds and that we actually use the
death of
george floyd's and others to actually
make policing uh
take it to the next level which is what
everyone wants including all the good
cops that are out there
that thankfully are more of them than
there are bad cops
most cops are are good but the fact is
the bad ones have to be identified and
prosecuted and out period
gwen how are you doing oh well i'm doing
pretty well
um as well as can be expected
you know i i'm sure that uh the words of
george floyd i can't breathe we're not
new to you and they echo in your mind
every single day six years ago
when your son died but we can't let this
keep happening what do you think the
next thing we have to do
gwen well first of all
i know when my son was murdered there
was a big
uprising but then it settled down
we can't let things settle down we have
to go to the politicians and we have to
hold their feet to the fire
because otherwise the big uprising is
not going to mean
a lot so i'm just asking that um
if you become the president that you
make sure
that we get national law as well as
state
and local law especially yeah i think
this second half hour is better than the
first half hour can we say that
no problem well i may be kidding myself
but i think the people are ready
i think people are ready we just got to
keep pushing
we can't let up but thank you for what
you're doing i really appreciate it
thanks for joining me thank you
thank you bye-bye thank you
racism structurally individually and
systematically
is real black brown no matter what you
look like you should not
ever be fearful of your life due to the
color of your skin
what i want to see the next president of
the united states is someone who's
fair who believes in equal justice under
the law
i want him to lead us through this
revolution that we're experiencing right
now joe biden is a healer
and he's a unifier he will fight for the
black lives matter movement
undo remove tear down the remnants of
structural and systematic racism in this
country
the systemic injustices that exist
things that our nation has overlooked
that need to be addressed we need to
stand on our platform and introduce
legislation that makes this platform
felt from coast to coast
and i know that joe biden is the person
to restore the values that we hold
so near and dear to our hearts i have a
10 year old son
i want to make sure that there is a
world that's left
better for him
good evening i'm congressman jim clyburn
here
in historic uh-oh
good evening i'm congressman jim clyburn
here in historic charleston south
carolina guess this is live
six months ago i stood not far from here
and endorsed joe biden
to be our 46th president it was a
decision i made with my feet
firmly planted in this community
this community for 80 of african
americans in this country
can claim an ancestor who arrive on
these shows
in bondage a few blocks from here over
at gaston's
wharf this community that is still
healing from the wounds we receive when
their white supremacists
entered emmanuel ame church and murdered
nine black parishioners
as they studied the bible together the
ground beneath our feet is seated with
pain
that is both old and new
but from that soil we always find a way
to grow
together earlier this summer the city of
charleston removed its statute
honoring john c calhoun an honored
advocate
of slavery and construction is underway
on the international african-american
museum at gadsden dwarf
much like the country as a whole we are
stepping out from the shadows of our
past
and beginning to lay the groundwork for
a more just
future it won't be easy
we can only succeed if we move forward
together
so we will need a president who sees
unifying
people as a requirement of the job
a president who understands the true
meaning
of community and how to build it through
trust
and humility and with so many families
experiencing loss
in this pandemic lost jobs
lost loved ones and lost confidence in
the president
to keep us safe we need a president who
understands
both profound loss and what it takes to
bounce back
but more important than his first-hand
experience with
loss and hardship is his ability to
translate
that perspective into policy and
solutions
and prioritize hard-working people
and persistent poverty counties over
partisan politics
or personal gain that's why i stand with
joe
and while he will always be an adopted
son
of south carolina joe biden is as good a
man
as he is a leader i have said before
and wish to reiterate tonight we know
joe but more importantly
joe knows us
i am kevin um i do a lot of things
in life but the thing i'm most proud of
is i'm a taps military mentor
and that's how i spend the majority of
my time post marine corps
building memories like the ones we build
together is the single best thing i do
with my time
thank you for allowing me to be a part
of your lives
and sharing the journeys for the past
decade we've got about 500
kids and family members and mentors and
we're all packed into this very
large ballroom and all of a sudden the
back door opens up
and interlocks joe biden
i had almost an out-of-body experience
because he surprised us all
you know i like to think i'm decent at
reading people from my time in the
marine corps my time as an intel officer
my time as a drill instructor my time
studying psychology he was being real i
mean you can't fake
that kind of a smile he was genuinely
happy
to see these kids and spend time with
them it's easy to lose faith in humanity
especially today there's a lot of
polarization
leaves a lot of room for a lot of hope
it's hard to articulate
real character when you see it you know
policies are great and we need sound
policies as well which
that he also has those because he's got
the chops right
but it's almost like none of that
matters if you don't have the character
this is a very unprecedented and
challenging time that requires an
unprecedented
and courageous leader we need someone
with the courage to do
what's necessary and what's right to
strive towards that more perfect union
that's joe biden i know joe
because he cares about everybody else
before himself
you know what else joe knows joe knows
about pandemics
in 2014 he helped stop the spread of
ebola
and brought the world together to keep
it contained and after that success
knowing this would happen again vice
president biden and president obama
assembled a pandemic playbook to make
sure that america
was prepared and protected that's true
the trump administration
disbanded the pandemic response team
that was given to them
americans have died and lost their
livelihoods because of it
we the people deserve a president who
believes in science
that recognizes the threat of covet who
has a plan to get us through it
and that is joe biden we're grateful
that across the country there are
responsible leaders who are stepping up
one of them provided clear direction and
memorable power points
new york's governor andrew cuomo
now they're getting from the speakers
today's monday day 170.
new yorkers were ground zero for the
covet virus
and have gone from one of the highest
infection rates on the globe to one of
the lowest
we climbed the impossible mountain space
looks different
the side we did it with the kindness and
assistance of so many
new yorkers want to thank everyone who
came to our aid
30 000 americans who volunteered to come
here to help in our hour of need
your love gave us the strength to carry
on
we went through hell but we've learned
much
we know that our problems go beyond the
covet virus covet is the symptom
not the illness our nation is in crisis
and in many ways covet is just a
metaphor
a virus attacks when the body is weak
and when it cannot defend itself
over these past few years america's body
politic has been weakened
the divisions have been growing deeper
the anti-semitism the anti-latino the
anti-immigrant fervor the racism in
charlottesville
where the kkk didn't even bother to wear
their hoods
and in minnesota where the life was
squeezed from mr floyd
only a strong body can fight off the
virus
and america's divisions weakened it
donald trump didn't create the initial
division
the division created trump right
he only made it worse our collective
strength is exercised through government
it is in effect our immune system and
our current federal government is
dysfunctional and incompetent
it couldn't fight off the virus in fact
it didn't even see it coming
the european virus infected the
northeast while the white house was
still fixated on china
the virus had been attacking us for
months before they even knew it was here
we saw the failure of a government that
tried to deny the virus
then tried to ignore it and then tried
to politicize it
the failed federal government that
watched new york get
ambushed by their negligence and then
watched new york suffer
but all through it learned absolutely
nothing
so today six months after it began
the nation is still unprepared and we
now face a second threat
but this time not from mother nature
this is a man-made threat
by our own negligence we now see the
virus ricocheting across the country
from one state to another today we
trail the world in defeating covet
we have over five million cases
americans learned a critical lesson
how vulnerable we are when we are
divided
and how many lives can be lost when our
government is incompetent
but we learned something else my friends
we saw the negative but we also saw the
positive
as they proved their way failed we
proved that our way
succeeded that america can still rise to
the occasion we can put our differences
aside and find commonality
government can tell the truth and can
build trust
we can judge by content of character
rather than color of skin we can care
for one another
that americans can work together and
forge community
and a competent government that of
course we will wear masks
because we are smart and because i care
about you and because you care about me
of course we will socially distance
because staying away
shows how close we actually are
yes we will set up testing and tracing
and do whatever we need to do to
mobilize to win this battle because we
are america
we win wars and we are the greatest
country on the globe
and for all the pain and all the tears
our way
worked and it was beautiful
we showed that our better angels are
strong and that americans will rise to
their call
we saw that even at the end of the day
even if it is a long day
that love wins americans eyes have been
opened
and we have seen in this crisis the
truth that government matters
and leadership matters
and it determines whether we thrive and
grow or whether we live or die
now we need a leader as good as our
people a leader who appeals to the best
within us not the worst
a leader who can unify not divide
a leader who can bring us up not tear us
down
i know that man i've worked with that
man
i've seen his talent i've seen his
strength i've seen his pain
and i've seen his heart that man is joe
biden
joe biden is what i call america tough
tough in the best way tough that is
smart
united disciplined and loving
joe biden can restore the soul of
america
and that's exactly what our country
needs today
thank you
best speaker so far focus on coronavirus
is logical given that
trump's failing on that issue hi i'm
kristin or kiesa
i'm one of the many who has lost a loved
one to covet
my dad mark anthony or kiesa should be
here today
but he isn't he had faith in donald
trump
he voted for him listened to him
believed him and his mouthpieces when
they said that coronavirus was under
control
and going to disappear that it was okay
to end social distancing rules before
it was safe that if you had no
underlying health conditions
you'd probably be fine so in late may
after the stay-at-home order was lifted
in arizona
my dad went to a karaoke bar with his
friends a few weeks later
he was put on a ventilator and after
five agonizing days
he died alone in the icu
with a nurse holding his hand my dad was
a healthy
65 year old his only pre-existing
condition
was trusting donald trump and for that
he
paid with his life i am not alone
once i told my story a lot of people
reached out to me to
share theirs they asked me to help them
keep their communities safe
especially communities of color which
have been disproportionately affected
best speakers they asked me a normal
person to help because donald trump
won't the coronavirus has made it clear
that there are two americas
the america that donald trump lives in
and the america that my father
died in enough is enough
donald trump may not have caused the
coronavirus
but his dishonesty and his irresponsible
actions made it so much worse
absolutely we need a leader who has a
national
coordinated data-driven response to stop
this pandemic
from claiming more lives and to safely
reopen the country which trump doesn't
have
we need a leader who will step in on day
one
and do his job to care
one of the last things that my father
said to me
was that he felt betrayed by the likes
of donald trump
and so when i cast my vote for joe biden
i will do it for
my dad right
thank you best speaker so far our nation
it's all scripted guys i mean i get
people saying it's all scripted it could
be good or bad
this virus it's a toll that hasn't
fallen equally
on us people of color have been
disproportionately affected
dying at greater rates than white
americans but we can honor
all of those we've lost by giving joe
biden and kamala harris the opportunity
to put in place a real national plan
that tests and tracks
that makes sure that access to a vaccine
will be fair
and turns the full power of our
government toward making sure we have
the supplies and technology and
people scientists and public health
officials and contact tracers
we need to stop this so right now
let's hear from a champion for our
frontline workers who also happens to be
an olympic champion and a world cup
champion
megan rapino hmm
hi everybody my name is megan repino and
i thought it was rappano
distinct honor today to host a
conversation
with four of our frontline workers here
in america
we should rename them heroes absolutely
trung lee can you tell us a little bit
about how you're doing during this time
so i'm going to i i i'm going to mute
this because
my plan was really mostly to focus on
not for any disrespect or anything but
focus on the primary
speakers so going at the list so far
we've already heard from governor andrew
cuomo
we heard from congressman jim clyburn we
heard from gwen moore
i believe maybe some of these
performances are the ones we heard from
and of course the big events today
are senator bernie sanders and former
first lady michelle obama
we are monitoring donald trump's twitter
to see if he gets triggered by what's
going on
so far no tweets whatsoever i have sent
a couple
and they've not been particularly
positive
um i could have done without the prayer
to jesus to kick it off
um and based on the first 22 minutes it
wasn't going so well given the
circumstances and given the limitations
of the format i i do think the second
half hour has improved cuomo was okay
um kristen or kisa was uh
what wasn't bad i don't know that the
rnc
is going to be any better these could
just be the limitations we're
effectively facing
um because of the format right i mean
maybe it can only be so good uh
super chats continue to come in bay
photo says fox news and hannity aren't
covering this that's not surprising
i do want to thank tyler lynn for the 50
super chat which is the high watermark
for the evening so far
and uh i i committed to opening the
phone lines if we were to get to
50 members stephen jones
is number eight today i do also want to
thank
katie roth who is number nine at
joinpackman.com
willie birdsall is new member number 10.
i guess since we're going for the 50 i
should just make it out of 50 right away
well not 205 out of 50.
um evan kallish or kalish
is new member number 11. we're counting
patreon and brad
james therefore gets us to number 12.
julie beatty kind of like warren beatty
or is it baby how is that properly
pronounced that's number 13. uh arturo
preciado
is number 14 and that's where we will
put a pause on it right now by the way i
am scheduled to do a spanish language
interview
on a spanish language show in a couple
of weeks i will have more information
for everybody
about that when i have more details
patrice mortimore says i wish we in
britain could join in your vote to
guarantee you get the leadership of joe
biden
there's a lot of kindness in his face
i want to say thank you to entropic
effect for the twitch prime subscription
very much appreciate that jriv checking
in
with biden harris 2020 emmanuel ramirez
vera says hate your views
thanks for skipping rapino oh give me a
break dude go away
um what in the world news says cuomo's
talent for insincerity
has so far been unmatched by the other
speakers
uh well-crafted message but i don't know
that i agree
michael rawley says i expected the
cringe to be much more intense
glad they're putting some meat on the
bones in the second half hour
on the whole better than expected
so a lot of different views going on
here
let's check back in and see what happens
next
[Music]
millions of people and veterans and
senior citizens rely on the postal
system for prescription
medicines for their checks having the
postal service to deliver my
prescriptions
became even more comforting when the
cover 19
virus hit us here in the united states
however now
with donald trump in office and his
attempts to
undermine the united states postal
service
we are extremely concerned this
administration's decision not to provide
the necessary
funding so i see a lot of people
complaining about filler
my preference would have been to do
longer speeches from the prominent
people
with small socially distanced crowds
responsibly done i think the level of
dynamism if that's a word would have
been dramatically higher
and that that's the way i would have
looked to do it no big events
right but but some you know socially
distanced
crowds crowds is you know audiences i
want to say
uh masks making it clear that that's the
responsible way to do it
maybe a little more engaging through
this crisis
americans are looking out for one
another it's time we had leadership in
washington that did the same
with joe biden in the white house and a
democratic senate
i know we can build back our economy and
our communities
even stronger but tonight i am here
to welcome someone who has strong ties
to our state and is here in maine with
me
she is reminding all of us to keep
fighting through
with her song that she's performing back
in my body
please help me welcome someone who's an
inspiration to all of us and one of my
favorite artists
maggie rogers
okay so i think we're going to continue
muting music
certainly if folks are interested in
these artists they can easily
find find them i just i don't know that
that's the biggest value add
necessarily joseph van scoy says the
platitudes are getting on my nerves
very little substance here
the beckminator says david i heard the
rnc was going to be hosted at the white
house is that true
yes as far as we know and if so does
that help trump more than biden given
the optics of such a thing
yes absolutely i mean there's just no
way to deny that at all
whatsoever a thank you to fatty mcblunts
for subscribing with twitch prime
uh leoncio zamora says you keep it
straight glad i found you buddy keep it
going this convention seems to be
dividing even more
coming from a democrat retro ambassador
says
were you planning on covering the alex
morse versus richie neil race
and the recent coverage from ryan grimm
of the intercept of the orchestrated
homophobic smear of alex morse by the
democratic party
yeah i've been texting with alex i've
known alex personally for a long time
and i believe he is scheduled to be on
let me take a look at our calendar here
oh he's on wednesday oh wait tomorrow
today's monday alex is going to be
joining me on wednesday so yes we're
going to be having alex on and
uh it feels like only yesterday i met
with alex at
sylvester's cafe in northampton
massachusetts
uh i had coffee i don't remember what he
had
i think there may have been muffins
involved and that was before he was even
um mayor of holyoke yeah so uh he i
believe he will be joining me
blue montserrat says david is a beta
male go jesse lee peterson hope that was
worth two bucks
benjamin spiegel says i thought biden
would pick
michael j creniss but harris is good too
i have no idea who that is or what the
joke is so maybe i just said some maybe
that's funny in some way and i just
don't really
um know how that's certainly possible uh
thanks to jonathan nowick who is new
member number 15 today
at also want to say thanks to
robert seidel or seidl who's new member
number 16 today
a jessica doyle is new member number
17 at joinpakman.com don't want to
forget
jake burns who is new member number 18
and we will get back to the coverage
entering our two we will have bernie
sanders kamala
i'm sorry not como harris michelle obama
etc
[Music]
[Music]
when the kovid 19 pandemic hit all i
could think about were my students and
their families
all the suffering and pain and
death that really didn't have to be this
way if we had leadership in place
that would have taken this pandemic
seriously in the beginning
we would not be in a situation we are in
we still at this time don't have the
necessary
ppe and i am very worried
about what is in front of us we're going
to have classrooms that maybe have not
been sanitized properly because we don't
have the money for that kind of
equipment
we're going to have classrooms packed
with students and so the virus is going
to be hard to contain
so this is very dangerous for the safety
of our kids i hope that the new
leadership takes american lives
seriously
i know joe biden understands that the
only way to keep people
safe and our economy strong is to follow
the recommendations of doctors
and we're going to do everything we can
to get joe
biden elected
okay on to hour two
next speaker please
hello america i'm governor gretchen
whitmer or
as donald trump calls me that woman from
michigan
tonight i'm here at uaw local 652 in
lansing michigan
auto workers in this union and across
our state
could have lost their jobs if not for
barack obama
and joe biden in 20 in 2009
the obama biden administration inherited
the worst economic crisis since the
great depression
the auto industry on the brink of
collapse
a million jobs at stake but president
obama
and vice president biden didn't waste
time blaming anyone else
or shirking their responsibility they
got to work
they brought together union members
companies
and lawmakers on both sides of the aisle
and they
saved the auto industry and wouldn't you
know
just a few months ago as our nation
began
battling covet 19 oh boy auto workers
across michigan
spring into action they started making
protective equipment for doctors
and nurses on the front lines let me
break it down
president obama and vice president biden
saved these auto workers
livelihoods then these workers did their
part
to save american lives
that's the story of this great nation
action
begets action progress begets progress
and when we work together we can
accomplish anything
after all democracy is a team sport
especially now it's crucial that we
rally together to fight this virus
and build our economy back better from
the jump
we took this pandemic seriously we need
either a pop filter or a drink of water
right
experts we planned and with a lot of
work from the auto workers
and too little help from the white house
we executed our plan
we saved thousands of lives
just imagine if we had a national
strategy
so everyone who needs a test gets one
for free so
everyone has access to a safe vaccine so
our kids and educators have the
resources they need to safely get back
to school
with joe biden and kamala harris in the
white house we will
joe biden and kamala harris will lead by
example
it'll be science not politics or ego
that will drive their decisions they
know the health of our people
goes hand in hand with the strength of
our economy
they know action begets action
over the past few months we've learned
what's essential
rising to the challenge not denying it
we've learned who is essential to
not just the wealthiest among us not a
president who fights his fellow
americans
rather than fight the virus that's
killing us and our economy
it's the people who put their own health
at risk
to care for the rest of us they are the
mvps the nurses and the doctors
the utility workers truck drivers and
grocery clerks
the child care workers the parents the
teachers
the mail carriers and the auto workers
so many of these essential workers have
lost their lives to covet
nearly a thousand health care workers
more than 170 000 people across
america including a five-year-old girl
named skyler from detroit
whose mom is a police officer and dad is
a firefighter
generation after generation our nation
has been defined by what we do
or what we fail to do
so for skylar for her parents
and in the memory of all those we've
lost
let us act let us heal as one nation
let us find strength to do the work
okay uh another one of the big names
promised for day one gretchen whitmer
there we go i've been down this road
before
um uh by continued popular demand we
will be uh
just checking in with different things
during the musical interlunes
interludes richard britton says
politicians suck all around check out
george carlin on
politicians fair fair point
susan farr and sarah maskey are new
members number 19 and 20 today
i also want to say thanks to omar
sanchez
brent childress alexander rastaino
and kimberly martin who are new members
number 21
22 23 and 24
at joinpackman.com i did accept the
challenge
really from like some guy on twitch i
don't know why that guy has so much
power but
i've agreed to open the phone lines if
we get to 50 new members today
back to evil longoria baston the people
even those with whom we might not agree
even those we might not expect to see at
a democratic convention
but joe biden is a guy who has earned
the respect he commands across the world
and across the aisle
the stakes in this election call for
that kind of leadership we have to think
about more than one party
we have to think about the very core of
our democracy
and that's why you're about to hear from
some unexpected voices
who's our special guest i'm governor
christine todd whitman what am i doing
here
i'm a lifelong republican my parents
were introduced at a republican national
convention by their parents that's how
far back it goes
but this isn't about a republican or
democrat it's about a person
a person decent enough stable enough
strong enough to get our economy back on
track a person who can work with
everyone
democrats and republicans to get things
done
donald trump isn't that person joe biden
is
i'm meg whitman i'm a long-time
republican and a long-time ceo
and let me tell you donald trump has no
clue how to run a business
let alone an economy joe biden on the
other hand has a plan that will
strengthen our economy for
working people and small business owners
for me
the choice is simple i'm with joe
hi i'm susan molinari i'm a former
republican member of congress from new
york city
and i've known donald trump for most of
my political career
so disappointing and lately so
disturbing 70 minutes in by the way the
first
ban hammer dropped for anti-semitism in
the chat
it can happen at any time folks it'll
hit you all of a sudden women
that's why i'm so proud to call him my
friend and honored to join in supporting
his candidacy for president
he's a really good man and he's exactly
what this nation needs at this time
now i'm delighted and honored to
introduce a former colleague of mine
the former congressman from ohio the
former governor of ohio
john basic america is at a crossroads
sometimes elections represent a real
choice a choice we make as individuals
and as a nation about which path we want
to take when we've come to challenging
times
america is at that crossroads today wow
the stakes in this election are greater
than any in modern times
many of us have been deeply concerned
about the current path we've been
following for the past four years
it's a path that's led to division
dysfunction
irresponsibility and growing vitriol
between our citizens continuing to
follow that path
will have terrible consequences for
america's soul
because we're being taken down the wrong
road by a president who is pitted
one against the other he's unlike all of
our best leaders before him who work to
unite
us to bridge our differences and lead us
to a united
america i'm a lifelong republican
right but that attachment holds second
place to my responsibility to my country
that's why i've chosen to appear at this
convention
in normal times something like this
would probably never happen
true but these are not normal times
i'm proud of my republican heritage it's
the party of lincoln
who reflected its founding principles of
unity
and a higher purpose but what i have
witnessed these past four years
belies those principles many of us
can't imagine four more years going down
this path
and that's why i'm asking you to join
with me in choosing
a better way forward wow i believe the
best of america lies ahead
but only when we rediscovered our shared
belief
in the united states of america
for our children's future which can be
bright
hopeful and inspired if we choose to
make it so
i've known joe biden for 30 years i know
his story of profound grief that has so
deeply affected his character
i know joe is a good man a man of faith
a unifier
someone who understands the hopes and
dreams of the common man and the common
woman
a man who can help us to see the
humanity
in each other he knows that the path to
a restored and rejuvenated america lies
in respect
and unity and a common purpose for
everyone
yes there are areas where joe and i
absolutely disagree
right but that's okay because that's
america
because whatever our differences we
respect one another as human beings
each of us searching for justice and for
purpose
we can all see what's going on in our
country today
and all the questions that are facing us
and no one person or party
has all the answers but what we do know
is that we can do better than what we've
been seeing today for sure
and i know that joe biden with his
experience and his wisdom and his
decency
can bring us together to help us find
that better way
i'm sure there are republicans and
independents who couldn't imagine
crossing over to support a democrat
they fear joe may turn sharp left and
leave them behind
i don't believe that no because i know
the measure of the man
no one has reasonable faithful
respectful
and you know no one pushes joe around
joe biden is a man for our times times
that call for all of us to take off our
partisan hats
and put our nation first for ourselves
and of course for our children
when america chooses the right path and
pulls together like we've done so many
times before
yeah we can dream big dreams and we can
see the top of the mountain
as a united states of america with a
soul
that is a beacon of freedom to the
entire world
so i i don't particularly care about
kasich being there although i do think
it's interesting but i
i think it's conceivable that there will
be some for example ohio republicans who
will see
kasich their republican governor that
they voted for
um and say well okay maybe he's right
maybe
it's it's a it's a blank check it's sort
of
okay you're getting cleared to go and
vote for joe biden people in ohio who
maybe
don't like what trump is doing but they
can't see themselves wait a second i'm
going to vote for a democrat
maybe you see kasich do this and then
you come over i don't know i think
that's really the only
um only real impact that uh
that that it could have it looks like
the second hour is going better than the
first we are waiting on bernie sanders
as well as michelle obama uh right are
they even going to be watching the dnc
but word will spread that kasich the
republican came over
um people seem to be joining back in
which we love
i think the last 45 minutes maybe the
best 45 minutes
um i uh quincy vigel
says the first hour was full of
platitudes and filler glad there's
finally some more
substance um okay
and now from alabama senator doug jones
doug jones who made her no longer be a
senator in three months okay yeah
growing up in the south meant growing up
in the midst of stark divisions
but it was here in alabama where rosa
parks helped ignite a movement
by refusing to give up her seat on a bus
where freedom riders of different races
came together
in pursuit of equality and it was here
in alabama
where john lewis marched across a bridge
toward freedom
from a young age i knew the hope that
comes from seeing good people
work to heal our divisions it's what led
me to become the united states attorney
where i convicted two klansmen who
murdered four young black girls
in a 1963 birmingham church bombing and
delivered long overdue justice
i'm standing in front of an exhibit
dedicated to their memory
alabama has shown me that even our
deepest divisions can be overcome
because each of us want the same thing
to be treated fairly and given the same
opportunities
and the freedom to live with dignity and
respect now
some politicians try to pit us against
each other
but i believe that americans have more
in common than what divides us
and in november we have a chance to
elect a president who believes that too
i've known joe for more than 40 years i
met him as a wide-eyed law student
and he's been my friend and champion
ever since
the joe i know is exactly the leader our
country needs right now
he can bring people together to find
common ground while standing up for what
he believes is right
after years of bitter partisanship he
can unite our country and get things
done for working families
and everyone looking for a better future
because it's not about what side of the
aisle we're on
it's about whether or not we're on the
side of the people
the great john lewis would often quote
the old african proverb
when you pray move your feet and then
challenge us to do just that
as a nation he said if we care for the
beloved community
we must move our feet our hands our
resources
to build and not tear down to reconcile
and not to divide
to love and not to hate to heal and not
to kill
in the final analysis we are one people
one family one house the american house
the american family vice president biden
understands that
and he is who we need as our next
president
here we are on a monday night in 2020
and we need to talk about the post
office
the u.s postal service right
it is central to so much of our lives
veterans
count on the post office to get their
prescriptions social security
beneficiaries count on the post office
to get their checks
grandparents depend on the post office
to send birthday cards to their
grandkids
small businesses need the post office to
do business
and guess what the post office is also
one of the ways
we cast our votes to find out how to
exercise that right
this november whether by mail or in
person
text vote v-o-t-e to 3-0-330
and here to say more is the first latina
elected to the united states senate
senator catherine cortez-masto
another one of the scheduled speakers
coming to us from our kitchen
hello i'm senator catherine cortez masto
from nevada
this year more americans than ever
before going to vote from rooms just
like this
marking their ballots at the kitchen
table and exercising one of our most
fundamental rights from home
but despite what the president says
voting by mail has been a secure
proven option for decades in 2016
33 million americans voted by mail even
donald trump has requested an absentee
ballot twice this year
this fall some americans will choose to
vote in a
voting booth with a mask on while many
of us will choose to vote by mail
my home state took the advice of
scientists and medical
some people in the chat don't seem to
believe she really has white appliances
and this is a green screen
system so voters have a lot of options
this fall
but donald trump is trying to divide us
by undermining that right
he has threatened to withhold federal
funding to nevada because of our vote by
mail system
that's funding our schools and seniors
rely on
he has challenged us in court with a
meritless lawsuit
one that our republican secretary of
state has asked the judge
to dismiss and now he is putting the
lives of nevada's seniors at risk
by trying to defund the post office
here's what that means
seniors won't be able to get their
prescriptions because he wants to win
an election well mr president nevada
is not intimidated by you america is not
intimidated by you we are united by
shared values
shared history and shared rights
including
our fundamental right to vote and this
fall
we will send joe biden to the white
house and we'll flip the u.s senate
with mitch mcconnell out of power and a
democratic majority in the senate
we will expand voting access and protect
voting rights to do this america
we need you on our side so go to
joebiden.com
right now to chip in and then head over
to flipthesenate.com
to help us take back the senate donald
trump and mitch mcconnell
know how to divide but we know how to
stand together
and turn this country around
wow this year we had an historic field
of presidential candidates
an historic number of women including
our vice presidential nominee kamala
harris
more candidates of color than any
primary ever
and the first openly gay man to win a
caucus
this party the democratic party welcomes
everyone
encourages everyone to lead and invites
everyone's ideas to ensure this country
builds back better this is what our next
speaker believes too
senator amy klobuchar ah here she is
this is her basement podium she keeps in
her basement
like my friend catherine i believe that
the right to vote is fundamental
and the post office is essential
you know the president may hate the post
office
but he's still going to have to send
them a change of address card
come january donald trump just happens
to be in my state today
trying to divide people instead of
responding the the pandemic
and the significant needs of our economy
but democrats
independents and yes many republicans
have had enough
of his divisiveness tonight my friends
in contrast we've heard a lot about how
we can unite as americans
about our shared values our shared
dreams how we've come together in the
face of crisis
but i want to be clear unity isn't about
settling
it's about striving for something more
it isn't the
end it's the means it's how we get stuff
done
unity is about reaching up toward a
higher purpose
a better future for all of us e
pluribus unum out of many one
it is more than a motto it is the north
star for our democracy
now more than ever we need a president
who will unite this country
we need a president who in george
floyd's memory
instead of using the bible as a prop
will heed
its words to act justly
we need a president for the workers
who've lost their jobs
because this administration is selling
american workers
out when we need to buy american for the
farmers and manufacturers
and the people of rural america who are
sick and tired of reaping what he's sown
we need a president who will look out
for the seniors like my dad
whose families now visit them through
glass windows
never knowing if it will be the last
time they see them
we need a president for all of america
i come from the middle of this country
where we believe in people
joining together to solve problems we
seek common ground
to reach higher ground that's been joe
biden's life's work
he's a man of scrappy working-class
roots
a man whose own hardships have only made
him more determined
to lift up those who have been left out
he understands redemption
and he knows resilience joe biden's a
man of deep experience
barack obama better known tonight as
michelle's husband
he leaned on joe for his strength and
decency
and you can too you know most candidates
when they end their campaign that day is
a hard one
for me it was a moment filled with great
joy
because the day i ended my presidential
campaign
was also the day i endorsed joe biden
joe ran for the same reasons i did when
i announced my campaign
in the middle of that blizzard on the
banks of the mississippi river
to cross the river of our divides to
bring this nation together
to be a president for all of america
as i said the day i endorsed him
if you feel stuck in the middle of the
extremes in our politics
if you are tired of the noise and the
nonsense you have a home with me
and you have a home with joe biden
that's why i was so proud to stand with
him then
and across this great country that's why
we are
all now standing united behind joe
and my friend kamala our nation's motto
is out of many one and as you're about
to see
it's also the story of the democratic
primary
thank you america right
cool lectern
we all ran for precedent motivated by
the same
reason as i watched president trump
divide this country more and more i
thought to myself
what are you willing to do to stop him
you had the most destructive
hateful racist president in the history
of this country
who is literally tearing apart the
fabric
of the united states of america donald
trump is a failed business person
and desperately failed us as a president
we will
run i ran for president because i think
it's urgent that we heal the divisions
in this nation
we are still in control of our own
future
and we need to provide millions of
americans a real path forward
a green jobs program increasing the
minimum wage
passing a national paid leave bill
student loan debt
mental health starting with our veterans
reproductive justice
economic justice racial justice and
there is so much a new
president can do to bring us together
it's time to
get up starting a presidential campaign
is daunting
i mean you have to reach hundreds of
millions of people
you have these incredibly long days
often capped off by these evening events
that go on for hours and hours
your challenge as a candidate is is to
be true to yourself and true to why
you ran in the first place that is
something by the way that i really
admire
about joe biden he really is his own man
he knows who he is
all right so we are if you're just
joining us we are about 75 percent of
the way through the first night
um and we are still standing by for
bernie sanders and michelle obama the
sort of keynote speakers this evening
and we could be joined by them
uh very very soon sometime in the next
half hour assuming that they're not
running behind we've seen the first hour
which was not so good
the first half hour was quite bad the
second half hour was a little bit better
and then the third half hour
has really been sort of okay as far as
what we
would expect and i know people are going
to be mad at me i'm not being positive
enough it's like come on guys you all
know who i'm voting for obviously i'm
voting for biden but
th this may just be a format difficulty
i do understand that
um corey keane or i'm sorry
sam goodwin says who in their right mind
can watch this without losing all hope
for the future
if you're impressed by tonight then
you're brain dead if you don't you're
enslaved by the two-party scam well i
think there are other options which are
you recognize that this is not so good
but but it doesn't necessarily mean all
of those uh all of those other things
that that that you're saying
um but this is uh this is this is
difficult so we're certainly going to
see whether bernie can kick up the
energy maybe michelle obama
um i do want to keep up with the new
members i did say if we got to 50 i
would open the phone lines when this is
done
we have brie williams josh tweedy
and dustin miller who get us numbers 25
26 and 27 also akshay
madane eric castellon
vic ultra jennifer kanaski
and eric bloom get us all the way
29 28 28 29 30
31 and 32 so that's
very very much appreciated and i see
people sending messages
on twitch the super chats continue to
come in people are very very excited
although not necessarily by the content
but they're at least excited to
participate
discarded toast subscribed with prime d
miller is just gifting subscriptions
like their candy
penny candy i might add which is really
great to see
and i see the super chats coming in
someone asked if i've ever seen
this slob referring to john kasich eat i
i haven't seen john kasich eat and quite
frankly
it doesn't really make too much of a
difference to me what he looks like when
he's eating as long as he holds his fork
correctly that's all i care about no i'm
kidding
that's that that would be elitist to say
that um okay
let's get back to this compilation
and we might be just minutes minutes
from senator bernie sanders
to the white house we've got one shot to
make donald trump
a one-term president and that shot is
right
now it's show time
[Applause]
right here we understand
that things are tough right now
economically but if we're going to beat
donald trump in november we need your
help
if you're able to go to joebiden.com and
chip in five
ten dollars whatever you can to fund the
change we need to
save our democracy because every bit
matters and it's going to take all of us
to make this happen and
no one knows that more than our next
speaker the biden harris campaign's
co-chair
representative cedric richmond from new
orleans louisiana okay
think about the places that make your
neighborhood feel like home
the barbershop where you can catch up on
the latest neighborhood news
while you get your hair cut the
restaurant where they know your order by
heart
or this art studio where a creative guy
with a great idea and a ton of hustle
turned an abandoned building into a
second home for the entire community
you know economists will tell you that
small businesses like this one
are critically important to our recovery
but they're also just plain important
without them the places we call home
just wouldn't be the same
that's the thing joe biden understands
that donald trump never has
and never will when we talk about the
economy
it's not just about the stock market
it's about whether you can find
work that really means something to you
instead of feeling like you're supposed
to be grateful just to get a paycheck
it's about whether people who didn't
inherit millions from their parents
can build a business from the ground up
and have a real chance to compete
and it's about whether in the richest
country on earth
everyone including women and people of
color
feel included and empowered economists
will also tell you
that joe biden's plan to rebuild our
economy
will create millions of jobs but joe
will tell you
that his plan is about more than that
because he's seen the world from a
different perspective than most
politicians
he knows what it's like to live in a
real neighborhood
not just penthouse apartments he knows
what it's like to take the train to work
not just a chauffeured limousine that's
why he looks at our economic challenges
the same way working people do
and he'll solve them in a way that puts
working people first
joe biden respects america's workers
because he truly
understands the dignity of work
you know it was mostly small talk when
we first met
when i would uh collect his ticket and
time went on i learned more and more
about him as our friendship crew
i think he's most comfortable around
everyday working class people
it just always makes you feel feel like
you belong
for more than 30 years joe biden took
the train to work
as a single dad he promised to be home
to kiss the boys every night
all right so i think we kind of
understand this storyline and we're
we're of course standing by for bernie
sanders and uh for
for michelle obama as well uh thanks to
jules for subscribing with prime as well
as discarded toast
um some other super chats i missed
anthony says thanks for all you do
wife just signed up also and stoked to
hear
her name around announced also
pronounced
beatty like 80. oh baby warren beatty
okay got it got it
yes uh very good aldo perensi's thoughts
on brett weinstein's unity 2020 idea
particularly as a viable option for 2024
i don't know i mean you know
brett weinstein that's a whole other
that's a whole other story
jamie l says please give the new york
governor kudos for his speech yeah it
was the best speech at that point
the best speech at that point um
who else do we have here uh oh this is
weird some of these are not showing up
like i just saw a new
super chat from love inspired
and yet it's not showing up on screen
here that's really strange
let me um
let me see here let me just refresh here
and see if we can get that back
on screen because there are some
interesting ones coming on
um and see if we're having any issues
there i will get back to that
but if i would have told that people in
the barbershop i don't think they would
have believed me
[Music]
i'm not saying it like it was me and i
was anything special everybody was
special to him
we have heroes all over this country and
a lot of the essential workers out there
that we don't even see that are behind
the scenes
are keeping this country going he
understands that
the average guy is important to him
the average guy is important to him
good evening here's bernie our great
nation
is now living in an unprecedented moment
we're facing the worst public health
crisis in a hundred years
and the worst economic collapse since
the great depression
we are confronting systemic racism and
the enormous threat to our planet of
climate change
and in the midst of all of this we have
a president
who is not only incapable of addressing
these crises
but is leading us down the path of
authoritarianism yes
this election is the most important in
the modern history
of this country indeed in response to
the unprecedented crises we face
we need an unprecedented response
a movement like never before of people
who are prepared
to stand up and fight for democracy and
decency
and against greed oligarchy
and bigotry and we need joe biden
as our next president wow let me take
this opportunity to say a word
to the millions of people who supported
my campaign
this year and in 2016. interesting
my friends thank you for your trust
your support and the love you showed
jane
me and our family together we have moved
this country in a bold
new direction showing that all of us
black and white latino native american
asian-american gay and straight
native-born
and immigrant yearn for a nation
based on the principles of justice
love and compassion our campaign
ended several months ago but our
movement continues
and is getting stronger every day
many of the ideas we fought for that
just a few
years ago were considered radical are
now mainstream
but let us be clear if donald trump is
re-elected
all the progress we have made will be in
jeopardy
at its most basic this election is about
preserving
our democracy during this president's
term
the unthinkable has become normal
something weird he has tried to prevent
people from voting
undermine the u.s postal service
deployed the military and federal
agents against peaceful protesters
threatened to delay the election and
suggested
that he will not leave office if he
loses
this is not normal streams
like it is under this administration
authoritarianism has taken root
in our country i and my family
and many of yours know the insidious way
authoritarianism destroys democracy
decency and humanity as long as i
am here i will work with progressives
with moderates and yes with
conservatives
to preserve this nation from a threat
that so many of our heroes fought
and died to defeat
this president is not just the threat to
our democracy
but by rejecting science he has put
our lives and health in jeopardy
trump has attacked doctors and
scientists
trying to protect us from the pandemic
while refusing to take strong action to
produce the masks
gowns and gloves our health care workers
desperately need bernie on fire nero
fiddled
while rome burned trump golfs
his actions fanned this pandemic
resulting in over a hundred
and seventy thousand deaths and a nation
still unprepared to protect its people
furthermore trump's negligence has
exacerbated
the economic crisis we are now
experiencing
since this pandemic began over 30
million people have lost their jobs
and many have lost their health
insurance millions of working families
are wondering
how they will feed their kids and
they're worried
that they will be evicted from their
homes and how has trump responded
instead of maintaining the 600 a week
unemployment supplement that workers
were receiving
and the twelve hundred dollar emergency
checks that many of you
received instead of helping small
businesses
trump concocted fraudulent executive
orders
that do virtually nothing to address the
crisis
while threatening the very future of
social security
and medicare but the truth is
that even before trump's negligent
response to this pandemic
too many hard-working families have been
caught
on an economic treadmill with no hope
of ever getting ahead together
we must build a nation that is more
equitable
more compassionate and more inclusive
i know that joe biden will begin
that fight on day one
let me offer you just a few examples of
how joe will move us forward
joe supports raising the minimum wage to
15
an hour that's true this will give 40
million workers a pay raise and push the
wage scale up
for everyone else joe will also make it
easier for workers to join unions
create 12 weeks of paid family leave
fund universal pre-k for three and
four-year-olds
and make child care affordable for
millions of families
joe will rebuild our crumbling
infrastructure
and fight the threat of climate change
by transitioning us to 100 percent clean
electricity
over the next 15 years what his plan
says these
initiatives will create millions
of good-paying jobs all across our
country
as you know we are the only
industrialized nation
not to guarantee health care for all
people
while joe and i disagree on the best
path to get universal coverage
he has a plan that will greatly expand
health care and cut
the cost of prescription drugs you heard
it further
he will lower the eligibility age of
medicare
from 65 down to 60.
to help reform our broken criminal
justice system
joe will end private prisons and
detention centers
cash bail and the school-to-prison
pipeline and to heal the soul
of our nation joe biden will end the
hate
and division trump has created he will
stop the demonization of immigrants
the coddling of white nationalists the
racist dog whistling
the religious bigotry and the ugly
attacks
on women my friends i say to you
to everyone who supported other
candidates in the primary
and to those who may have voted for
donald trump in the last election the
future of our democracy
is at stake the future of our economy
is at stake the future of our planet
is at stake very much so we must come
together
defeat donald trump and elect joe biden
and kamala harris as our next president
and vice president my friends
the price of failure is just too great
to imagine thank you
wow senator bernie sanders
many people liking it big sos man says
breaking bernie gives us
wood during this speech nick cerebino
says how did the other guy beat this guy
um joe schmoe says who would be kamila's
vp in your opinion no idea
love inspired says good lord david there
are a lot of trouble making trolls in
this room let me know if you need an
extra moderator for about an hour or two
i love booting trolls out of rooms
very very important and powerful message
we are now waiting for michelle obama
uh i will open phones at the top of the
hour if we get to 50 members we now have
jose via carl miller
robert johnson mark mckeever
dano and wait one two three four
five uh that gets us
to uh 37
oh my god it might actually happen
um and okay we're at 37 right now with
michelle obama coming up
long to hear right now are the ones that
speak with courage
and kindness strength and wisdom love
and compassion they're unafraid to speak
the truth and talk about their own
uncertainties and struggles they make us
feel seen and inspire us to become the
best versions of ourselves
our next speaker is that for all of us
it is my honor and privilege to
introduce
the former first lady here we go
michelle obama
good evening everyone it's a hard time
and everyone's feeling it in different
ways
and i know a lot of folks are reluctant
to tune into a political convention
right now
or to politics in general believe me i
get that
but i am here tonight because i love
this country with all my heart
and it pains me to see so many people
hurting
i've met so many of you i've heard your
stories
and through you i have seen this
country's promise
and thanks to so many who came before me
thanks to their toil and sweat and blood
i've been able to live that promise
myself
that's the story of america
all those folks who sacrificed and
overcame
so much in their own times because they
wanted something more
something better for their kids
there's a lot of beauty in that story
there's a lot of pain
in it too a lot of struggle and
injustice
and work left to do and who we choose as
our president in this election
will determine whether or not we honor
that struggle
and chip away at that injustice and keep
alive
the very possibility of finishing that
work
i am one of a handful of people living
today who have seen
firsthand the immense weight and
awesome power of the presidency and
let me once again tell you this
the job is hard it requires clear-headed
judgment
a mastery of complex and competing
issues
a devotion to facts and history a moral
compass and an ability to listen
and an abiding belief
that each of the 330 million lives
in this country has meaning and worth
a president's words have the power to
move markets
they can start wars or broker peace
they can summon our better angels or
awaken our worst instincts
you simply cannot fake your way through
this job
as i've said before being president
doesn't change who you are it reveals
who you are
well a presidential election
can reveal who we are to and four years
ago too many people
chose to believe that their votes didn't
matter
maybe they were fed up maybe they
thought the outcome wouldn't be close
maybe the barriers felt too steep
whatever the reason yes in the end
those choices sent someone to the oval
office who
lost the national popular vote by nearly
3 million votes
very much so in one of the states that
determined the outcome
the winning margin averaged out to just
two votes per precinct two votes
and we've all been living with the
consequences
when my husband left office with joe
biden at his side
we had a record-breaking stretch of job
creation
we'd secured the right to health care
for 20 million people we were respected
around the world
rallying our allies to confront climate
change
and our leaders had worked hand-in-hand
with
scientists to help prevent an ebola
outbreak
from becoming a global pandemic
four years later the state of this
nation
is very different more than 150 000
people have died
and our economy is in shambles because
of a virus that this president
downplayed for too long
it has left millions of people jobless
too many have lost their health care too
many
are struggling to take care of basic
necessities
like food and rent too many communities
have been left
in the lurch to grapple with weather and
how to open
our schools safely internationally we've
turned our back
not just on agreements forged by my
husband
but on alliances championed by
presidents like
reagan and eisenhower and here at home
as george floyd brianna taylor
and a never-ending list of innocent
people of color
continue to be murdered stating the
simple fact that a black life matters
is still met with derision from the
nation's highest
office because whenever we
look to this white house for some
leadership or
consolation or any semblance of
steadiness
what we get instead is chaos division
and a total and utter lack of empathy
empathy that's something i've been
thinking a lot about lately
the ability to walk in someone else's
shoes
the recognition that someone else's
experience
has value to most of us practice this
without a second thought
if we see someone suffering or
struggling
we don't stand in judgment we reach out
because there but for the grace of god
go i
it is not a hard concept to grasp it's
what we teach our children
unlike so many of you barack and i have
tried our best
to instill in our girls a strong moral
foundation
to carry forward the values that our
parents and grandparents poured into
us but right now
kids in this country are seeing what
happens when we
stop requiring empathy of one another
this is actually pretty good they're
looking around wondering if we've been
lying you don't have to think obamacare
is the best to recognize this is good
what we truly value they see people
shouting in grocery stores
unwilling to wear a mask to keep us all
safe
they see people calling the police on
folks minding their own business
just because of the color of their skin
they see an entitlement that says only
certain people belong here that greed is
good and winning is
everything because as long as you come
out on top
it doesn't matter what happens to
everyone else
and they see what happens when that lack
of empathy
is ginned up into outright disdain
[Music]
they see our leaders labeling fellow
citizens
enemies of the state while emboldening
torch-bearing white supremacists
they watch in horror as children are
torn from their families and thrown
into cages and pepper spray and rubber
bullets
are used on peaceful protesters for
photo-op
sadly this is the america that is on
display for the next generation
a nation that's underperforming not
simply on matters of policy but on
matters
of character and that's not just
disappointing
it's downright infuriating
because i know the goodness and the
grace
that is out there in households and
neighborhoods
all across this nation and i know
that regardless of our race age
religion or politics when we close out
the noise and the fear
and truly open our hearts
we know that what's going on in this
country
is just not right
this is not who we want to be
so what do we do now what's our strategy
over the past four years a lot of people
have asked me when others are going so
low
does going high still really work
my answer going high
is the only thing that works because
when we go
low when we use those same tactics
of degrading and dehumanizing others we
just become
part of the ugly noise that's drowning
out everything else
we degrade ourselves we degrade the very
causes for which we fight
but let's be clear going high does not
mean
putting on a smile and saying nice
things when confronted by viciousness
and cruelty
right going high means taking the harder
path
it means scraping and clawing our way to
that mountaintop
going high means standing fierce against
hatred
while remembering that we are one nation
under god
and if we want to survive we've got to
find a way
to live together and work together
across
our differences and going high means
unlocking the shackles of lies and
mistrust
with the only thing that can truly set
us free
the cold hard truth
so let me be as honest and clear as i
possibly can
donald trump is the wrong president for
our country
he has had more than enough time to
prove that he can do the job but he
is clearly in over his head he cannot
meet this moment
he simply cannot be who we need him to
be
for us it is what it is
now i understand that my message won't
be heard by some people
we live in a nation that is deeply
divided
and i am a black woman
speaking at the democratic convention
but enough of you know me by now
you know that i tell you exactly what
i'm feeling
you know i hate politics but you also
know that i
care about this nation you know how much
i care about all of our children
so if you take one thing from my words
tonight
it is this if you think things
cannot possibly get worse trust me they
can
and they will if we don't make a change
in this election
if we have any hope of ending this chaos
we have got to vote for joe biden like
our lives
depend on it for many people it does
i know joe he is a profoundly
decent man guided by faith
he was a terrific vice president he
knows what it takes to rescue an economy
beat back a pandemic and lead our
country
and he listens he will tell the truth
and trust science he will make smart
plans
and manage a good team and he will
govern
as someone who's lived a life that the
rest of us can recognize
when he was a kid joe's father lost his
job
when he was a young senator joe lost his
wife and his baby daughter
and when he was vice president he lost
his beloved son
so joe knows the anguish of sitting
at a table with an empty chair which is
why he gives his time
so freely to grieving parents joe knows
what it's like to struggle
which is why he gives his personal phone
number to kids
overcoming a stutter of their own
his life is a testament to getting back
up
and he is going to channel that same
grit and
passion to pick us all up to help
us heal and guide us forward
now joe is not perfect and he'd be the
first to tell you that
but there is no perfect candidate no
perfect president
and his ability to learn and grow
we find in that the kind of humility
and maturity that so many of us yearn
for right now
because joe biden has served this
nation his entire life without ever
losing
sight of who he is but more than that
he has never lost sight of who we
are all of us
joe biden wants all of our kids to go to
a good school
see a doctor when they're sick live on a
healthy planet and he's got plans to
make all of that happen
joe biden wants all of our kids no
matter what they look like to be able
to walk out the door without worrying
about being harassed or
arrested or killed he wants all
of our kids to be able to go to a movie
or a math class without being afraid
of getting shot he wants all our kids
to grow up with leaders who won't just
serve themselves and their wealthy peers
but will provide a safety net for people
facing hard times
and if we want a chance to pursue any of
these goals
any of these most basic requirements for
a functioning society
we have to vote for joe biden in numbers
that cannot be ignored because right now
folks who know they cannot win fair and
square at the ballot box are doing
everything they can
to stop us from voting they're closing
down
polling places in minority neighborhoods
they're purging voter rolls they're
sending people out to intimidate voters
and they're lying about the security of
our ballots
these tactics are not new
but this is not the time to withhold our
votes in protest
or play games with candidates who have
no chance of winning
we have got to vote like we did in 2008
and 2012.
we've got to show up with the same level
of
passion and hope for joe biden we've got
to vote early
in person if we can we've got to request
our mail and ballots
right now tonight yesterday and send
them back immediately
and follow up to make sure they're
received and then make sure our
friends and families do the same we have
got to grab our comfortable shoes
put on our masks pack a brown bag dinner
and maybe breakfast too
because we've got to be willing to stand
in line
all night if we have to
look we have already sacrificed so much
this year
so many of you are already going that
extra mile
even when you're exhausted you're
mustering up
unimaginable courage to put on those
scrubs and give our loved ones a
fighting chance
even when you're anxious you're
delivering those packages stocking those
shelves
and doing all that essential work so
that all of us can keep moving forward
even when it all feels so overwhelming
working parents are somehow piecing it
all together without child care
teachers are getting creative so that
our kids can still learn and grow
our young people are desperately
fighting to pursue their dreams
and when the horrors of systemic racism
shook
our country and our consciences
millions of americans of every age every
background
rose up to march for each other
crying out for justice and progress
this is who we still are
compassionate resilient
decent people whose fortunes
are bound up with one another and it is
well past time for our leaders to once
again
reflect our truth so
it is up to us to add our voices
and our votes to the course of history
echoing heroes like john lewis who said
when you see something that is not right
you must say something you must do
something
that is the truest form of empathy
not just feeling but doing
not just for ourselves or our kids
but for everyone for all our kids
and if we want to keep the possibility
of progress alive in
our time if we want to be able to look
our children in the
eye after this election we have
got to reassert our place in american
history
and we have got to do everything we can
to elect
my friend joe biden as the next
president
of the united states thank you all
god bless
a little long but very good
very very good overall
hitting a lot of very very important
topics there
uh certainly a good speaker will we be
opening up the phone lines i don't know
if we're going to hit 50.
channa mccartney has signed up brian
peterson
alex mateen robin scott
and donald schertz you are what we miss
in this country we need more of that
example thank you
so much for being part of this
unconventional convention
thanks to all of y'all who have been
tuning in it's a it's a convention about
you
and for you the american people this is
our chance
to hear from those who will be leading
um leading us out of our nation out of
the current crisis
on the economy the pandemic racial
injustice
to listen and to learn about joe biden
and kamala harris's plans to
bring about changes we all need this is
our chance
to unite across america in addition
we'll call the roll
and we'll hear from the future first
lady dr
jill biden i want to thank you again for
joining us
join us the rest of the week this is
your convention this is your
campaign and we the people are going to
save
this democracy in november right now
billy porter
and steven stills are going to remind us
what it's all worth
good night all right wrapping up there
uh the first of four nights started slow
bernie very good michelle obama very
good
uh overall it's a difficult format and
unfortunately because donald trump will
be doing it at the white house
i would be shocked if he didn't put
together some kind of crowd
i think the dynamics and the optics may
be
problematic the sort of uh fully
produced two-hour thing
coming in and out of live stuff with
clips and pre-recorded
um i think compared to what trump plans
to do
maybe a little tough it may be a little
tough there's no question about it
let's see what's going on people want to
hear this
[Music]
i guess this will allow a few more
minutes during which if we got to 50
members i'd open the phone lines but
it's
if people want the phone lines open i'll
let it i'll let the numbers run until we
get to this two more just signed up
[Music]
is
[Music]
down
[Music]
it will creep
[Music]
it starts when you're always afraid
[Music]
is
tony's number 46.
aaron's number 47
dave it's number 48
we the people call the 48th quadrennial
democrat
you guys failed to do it you guys
failed to do it the end of the first day
and we are
only at 48 but you know what just to be
nice
i'll take a couple phone calls i will
take a couple okay
we have a new system it's on discord
it's davidpakman.com
discord if you want to get on with me
get into the waiting lobby
um i guess is what it's called i
even though we didn't make it just
because we were so close
i will take just a couple of calls okay
it's davidpakman.com
discord i'm going to do a couple just as
a little extra
because it'd be weird at 48 to bail even
though we
didn't really make it okay so it's
davidpakman.com
discord that's the official discord
any other discord is not official i'm
just going to check in with a couple of
people okay
let's try uh
let's try alexander
the sixth okay let's go first to
alexander vi
and see what's going on um
where is this oh alexander's gone
okay let's try tonight out
well that didn't work either hold on a
second
tonight out okay tonight out can you
hear me
tonight out can you hear me
tonight out's gone all right let's try
let's try white night white knight can
you hear me it shows you as being muted
right now maybe
unmute white knight if you'd like to be
able to speak
hello hello we've got somebody it's
working okay what's going on
oh nothing much uh thanks for taking my
call uh my name is bernardo from houston
texas
supporter of the show big fan of the
show thank you
um i guess uh i i think i had the same
feelings as you did during the beginning
of the
dnc it was a little trepid i guess you
could say and
i guess it could i guess you could say
it finished off strongly
do you mean tepid uh maybe yes maybe
right yeah yeah yeah it started tepid i
got you yeah i got better
it definitely got better i mean listen
it was good enough that i'm gonna watch
the second night let's put it that way
and then we'll see where the second
night gets us
well all right there you go there you go
well okay thank you david
all right thank you very good it seemed
like he didn't really expect to get on
uh let's see we're just talking to a
couple people on discord let's go to
a p.r mccartney
p.r mccartney um
oh boy is this thing even working pr
mccartney can you hear me
it's back to white night somehow that's
weird a lot of people seem to be bailing
uh now how do i remove oh i drag out
okay so we've got a drought
then they left okay let's try this is
the first time with the new system we're
going to
trev dog okay trev dog
is next trev dog please unmute you are
on
hello yeah
either give me one sec please please
take your time sounds like you're
finishing up an email
i don't have 40 people trying to get on
or anything
i'm curious where this is gonna go
can you hear me yes
okay um
i can hear you yeah i can hear you too
all right and then they just left well
listen we established
that we could hear each other and then
so
everybody told me david if you use
discord the calls will be beautiful
they'll be perfect phone calls like
trump
not so far not so far let's go to
um let me go here to
how about kevin klotzfelter can we go to
kevin klotfelter you're
the next person on um
kevin klotzfelter okay kevin please
unmute you are on right now
all right can you hear me yes i can
awesome
what can i do for you hey david how you
doing
uh so i've been trying to figure out how
to sort of approach
everything that's happening with my more
conservative friends and family
yeah uh i did see what you know when you
were talking to joe rogan sort of
someone who's
not really far on the left i guess do
you just have any
any advice on how to approach that topic
with uh
people that really um don't
are kind of a political or more
conservative
hold on are they political or are they
conservative though
uh i think those lines kind of get
blurred
at some points and i don't know how to
how to really
um there's sort of this like gray area
that i've
found with friends and family where they
lean conservative but are not really
into politics
um okay and your goal is to do what
i guess just make them aware of of what
is happening with
with the current situation regarding
cobia 19 and the
that it's actually a problem that's
happening um and just sort of the
the mismanagement under the trump
administration
well if that's the case then i would
first start by asking them what their
beliefs are and how they came to those
beliefs i mean
it's it's sort of it's a bit vague so
i'm trying to give an answer that might
encompass what you're trying to do but i
think in general if you're trying to
change minds
you're going to do better with a
respectful empathetic socratic method of
questioning
rather than beating people over the head
with with facts essentially for lack of
a better term
yeah no absolutely actually well i
appreciate your thoughts
all right well good luck with that um i
hope that i hope that it goes well
um that can be uh that can certainly be
a
you know you can have a big matzo ball
hanging out there uh
let's see um oh destiny
wants to chat uh yeah let's do it real
quick i'm not gonna be on too much
longer but destiny wants in so let me
see if i can get him
um i'm calling stephen kenneth destiny
bennell ii right now because people
wanted to hear from him and something
about
milo i don't even know stephen are you
there is this
david deepak um david pakman from twitch
tv hello
this is david deepak pakman destiny the
second
yeah wow you've uh evolved you've
mutated
somebody say so what it what did you
think of the dnc stuff
i'm gonna be completely honest with you
i um
i mean my fan base knows originally i
backed tulsi gabbard and i kind of
flirted with yang
then i you know took a hard left into
bernie oh my god and after
after after after donna came out again
and stole the election for bernie i was
thinking
you know i'm i'm done you know i'm a
hard left
super liberal borderline communist but
you know i'm just going to vote for
trump because if they're going to take
it from
bernie like why not but after watching
so many brave people come forward
tonight
and give their takes on how damaged they
are by this economy
by covet 19 by the atrocious production
quality
of this video broadcast and by
everything else that's going on in this
country
you know i think i think joe's gonna
earn my vote by the end of day seven
of this um of this youtube premiere
series because
wow i loved it i i mean i just i i loved
it from start to finish
the problem when you asked me that
question i get a little bit nervous
because i'm trying to think of a single
moment that i didn't love
yeah can you can you can you give me
summer the christian prayer and invoking
jesus i didn't love
really you hate jesus or you hate
religiosity or you hate christians or
what's your what's your problem i just
don't think it has a place
in a nominating convention you really
don't think so
no huh well i mean for me personally i
feel like god kind of guides all of my
actions
um to pretend that we can disassociate
god from the political process when he
leaves and breathes uh lives and
breathes through all of us um
i don't know i are you doing material
right now i'm trying to figure out
what's going on
like material like dialectic materialism
that's what i used to do back when i was
a bernie fan
but yeah hey um
did things go bad when boat has coached
me is that what happened
hello you know it's stung a little
hey you sound despondent you're bare i'm
worried about
is is everything okay are you streaming
right now i am streaming you know
um sorry i keep getting messages from my
new best friend milo so uh you cut out
sometimes um
i'm sorry what did you say something
about backstabbing me for a chess
tournament
oh man i don't even know how to i mean
it's like it's like i'm interviewing the
cat i'm instead of instead of
interviewing kenny who's the guy i know
i'm interviewing
destiny the character it feels like yeah
well
okay let's rewind a little bit okay
honestly i don't know
i i don't know i don't believe that
we're the target audience for this stuff
but i don't know who is
right maybe that's what it is yeah like
because the truth is
i'm voting by i'd crawl over broken
glass to vote for biden
so it's like what do i why they don't
need to appeal to me
maybe they're smarter and they've
figured out who are we actually trying
to reach with this nonsense
yeah it kind of feels like um we're
older i don't know or maybe they did
this for younger people too
you remember a long time ago i feel like
i used to see on tv more often like
the big fundraisers for things where
they'd bring in celebrities and they'd
sing songs and they'd go
back and forth like cutting from scenes
of the scene like that really weird like
fundraising stuff
yeah it felt like i was kind of watching
one of those um there was an element of
telethon yeah
yeah yeah yeah telethon yeah one of
those yeah that's what it felt it was
very strange
yeah especially and then they even had
like the call to action to donate at the
end
yeah and then like some people say three
oh
three three oh like they've got to get
on the same page also from the
standpoint of how to say that five-digit
number
or just register every variation i guess
if they if they're gonna mess it up so
much well that's the emphasis
i feel like they're doing the emphasis
really weirdly i don't know
uh-huh yeah so when i release i mean i
don't know
i just yeah i wasn't sure who this was
targeted at man i was
i love this kind of stuff like politics
is what i mean we talk about it all day
right so i figured it was gonna be fun
stuff but man this was just
so unbelievably boring oh my god after
about an hour i was almost ready to tap
out
but the second hour was better than the
first right it
it was but i was already so exhausted
and
fatigued from the first hours it was
harder to appreciate you know the
kasich talking to a drone for five
minutes or you know like it was harder
to
the second half did pick it up a little
bit though yeah have you been dropping
the banhammer on people in the chat
pretty frequently or how is how are you
how's that all going
um for some things yeah what are you are
you referring to something in particular
no no no i just i it's weird i'll be
just talking about something unrelated
and all of a sudden there's like virile
and anti-semitism and the ban hammers
being dropped like crazy it's just weird
how it happens
oh yeah i mean i've been i mean i think
i've weeded most of those people out of
my community but
oh is that right and by the way i'm i
pulled up your stream now
where where are you right now you seem
to be in some other place you've got an
electrical box panel behind you i hope
that that's 120 volt service
um well why would you hold that what if
i'm in europe
maybe you are i mean it sort of looks
like a european uh like kind of studio
hotel that i stayed in in helsinki
yeah well close um i'm actually in a new
jersey but it's kind of like europe i
guess
you know that's not exactly what i would
associate uh
new jersey would necessarily but so are
you are you going to cover all four
nights of this
or i i mean i i feel like if i the thing
is is i have to because if i don't if
i'm doing anything else
my chat is just going to be full of
people that are going to come in and
scream like
are you going to watch the deal where's
the dnc debate this night too you're
going to blah blah blah like ah you know
i don't know does your audience like you
do you think sometimes i feel like your
audience doesn't like you
it's one of those like
my audience is um you ever see the movie
inception yeah
my audience is like the dying dad at the
end where he's like you know
it seems like i hated you all this time
but i didn't really hate you i just i
wanted you to be better than me
you know that's my audience it's like
you know they give me a lot of [ __ ] all
the time because they expect a lot out
of me yeah i think
they love me but they would need to be
on like death store to admit it you know
and what is that is that a huge soda
that you have in front of you or what is
that
yeah i got some white castle so i could
you know acquaint myself with some
good new jersey food huh and then i see
also something like is that does that
say niagara over your left shoulder or
viagra what is that
you know i'm not entirely sure i'm sorry
are you playing [ __ ] where's waldo
tonight what are you gonna identify
everything in my background
it also i mean this is weird but is that
a prosthetic leg on the desk
over your left shoulder are you talking
about the bag of food
oh you're talking about the french fries
no i mean i i maybe if you were macgyver
you could fashion a prosthetic leg
oh there okay okay okay okay got it got
it got it got it got it okay oh it's
friends are you going to cover
you must cover all four knights of this
right i think i have to
i told my audience that if the first
night didn't go well i wasn't going to
i guess it went well enough where i
probably will cover all four nights yeah
but
what's crazy is then friday
pog champs two starts and i'm playing
it's hafu which i'm told is the best
player in the tournament i'm gonna get
destroyed and i'm gonna be busy all week
where i won't even be able to prepare i
thought weren't you supposed to be
pretty good at chess
no i'm like i lost to you in a 30-second
game what are you talking about well
i mean i'm very do you know who you're
talking i used to be a professional
starcraft player strategy is just like
part and parcel it's part of who i am oh
huh
weird i'm curious um for your uh
moderation team uh do you vet all of
your moderators yourself well you're
talking about the banham earlier
yep uh corey cory check um
level four uh basically it's like as if
you were gonna be border patrol they go
through all the same vetting process
crazy yeah i'm curious what kind of
vetting process did greenman137 go
through
i have no idea i don't know who that is
man that guy really doesn't i've just
been reading his
stuff about me and chat you know he said
he'd never be friends with a troll ass
racist punk like destiny um this is what
your moderators think about me
destiny [ __ ] sucks baby
he seems to be uh pretty upset yeah i
just see a lot of um
i think the term is ass pain that seems
like no that sounds aggressive we're
gonna have to look into that
um hey are you engaged also i heard you
were engaged
um yeah kind of with molina yeah
kind of i like that that's interesting
you're not i mean she's swedish so you
like you never really know right like
it's kind of
is that a cultural difference there's a
lot of cultural differences yeah
species different sometimes swedish are
very weird people and have you guys been
separated for some time now
yeah actually um in a few days i'm going
to try to sneak into sweden i heard that
if you're a really good debater
if you land you can make a really good
argument to get in they'll let you in so
it's gonna be i didn't realize sweden
had banned americans i thought it was
just about everybody else
well the entire european union i think
has a travel restriction on the us so
oh and as far as i know sweden is still
part of
the eu son um i have friends who went to
the uk
and did two weeks there and once you're
there you're kind of established and
then you can go elsewhere
yeah you can do that i don't know if i
want to stay in the uk for two weeks we
all have our limits you know
um not not two weeks in the uk and then
two weeks in sweden that's just that's
too much
european for me would you stream from
europe
um yeah i mean i tried to yeah you would
okay if i'm if i'm gone for that many
weeks yeah i'd like to stream when i
travel again
and then the last thing because it's
it's getting to be past my bedtime
what um has anything been
kind of um what's the word rekindled
with hassan [ __ ] are things bad still
um well i think that our entire
relationship is just
um eternally doused in gasoline so a
rekindling of anything would just be a
reignition
of our everlasting hatred for each other
it's a tinderbox essentially
um yeah i would say so yeah
uh do you think as white in pog champs
should i be playing the vienna or
ponziani
oh man um the problem is that the vienna
is just so well studied at this point i
think that everybody's gonna be prepared
for it the ponziani because you have so
many more options i think in like the
early mid game
um i i would run that if i were you are
you being serious that actually seems
like a reasonable
reaction wait yeah wait do you think i
just
do you think i don't know anything about
chas i thought that was i thought you
were going to give me a bs answer i'll
be
perfectly frank no of course not i mean
it depends on how comfortable you are
playing past like a couple openings
right
completely uncomfortable i have no
memory whatsoever of what to do
oh well yeah i i have no idea what
either of those things are i'm sorry i'm
sorry okay
i'm sorry very good uh all right well
listen
let's check in again later in the week
and see how things are going and then
we'll talk about the bow test thing i do
want to figure out what's going on there
um that's a pretty soft that's a pretty
soft spot for me pretty tender spot so
i'd leave that one alone that one you
would recommend staying away from it
sounds like yeah we could talk about a
sun all you want but
fair enough all right stephen kenneth
destiny bennell the second um
the man the myth the legend always a
pleasure talking to you
thank you david d pacman pacman
of twitch.tv i look forward to talking
talking to you after a couple more
nights at the dnc
yeah all right take care talk to you
soon bye to destiny's audience
yeah see you later deepak's audience wow
wow what a night i mean i couldn't
imagine a better way
to completely torpedo the evening
uh than opening up the phone lines and
then uh talking to destiny no i'm
kidding
it's great to talk to him and uh from
you know i think
things may have been a little weird
after our big brunch
but i think things have gone okay let's
just see what he's saying now hold on
let's take a listen
that crazy oh that mod [ __ ] hates me
holy [ __ ]
i always feel like you talk to deepak
are [ __ ] new segments and you're
cramming in as many memes as possible
well
he um he [ __ ] memes so hard i feel
like i have to
or else i just end up getting [ __ ]
hardcore out memed right you could get
it and
you could end up being memed up the
wazoo okay everybody so
if anybody has funny clips or whatever
from the destiny thing
uh send them to me it's way past my
bedtime
people are telling destiny i'm still
watching him all right i'm out i'll see
everybody tomorrow